post brexit the UK government insists
the country will be open for business
but under new immigration rules outlined
on Wednesday many kinds of people who've
been able to live and work here for
decades are having the door closed on
them we are no longer going to have a
route for low-skilled workers to come to
the UK this will now be a single global
system that does not discriminate as to
whether or not you come from the EU or
from outside of the EU so how will this
new system work well it'll be Points
Based there'll be no cap on the number
of people eligible and no longer will
you citizens get preferential treatment
there are three things that incoming
workers will need a job offer from an
approved employer that job must be at
the right skill level and speaking
English is a must but workers with all
of these will still need something else
to make up the points maybe they've
completed all their school
qualifications
maybe they'll earn over $33,000 or above
the going rate for their fields or maybe
there's a shortage of workers in their
occupation but there's an issue with
shutting out all of it the
highly-skilled and many business leaders
are pointing it out low-skilled or low
paid jobs are essential for the economy
and the UK doesn't have enough of its
own citizens willing to do them shut out
the immigrants who've been fitting them
for decades and you've got a problem if
we have a turning off of any access to
that lower paid end of the job market
care workers labourers on construction
sites hospitality workers waitresses
kitchen workers food processes we will
potentially see some businesses unable
to expand and grow and it will affect
the growth rate of the economy
the Home Secretary says the slack could
be taken up by the eight point four
million British adults who aren't
working drill into the data though and
most of students sick carers all retired
perhaps only a million Brits are
available for these jobs even if they
wanted them Rory challon's now
Zera London